[Music]
ten cc's Fiasco needs are submitted by
Alexandria Haughton him father recounts
the hilariously disgusting moment his
baby daughter played with her poop
baby daughter poop blue time like a
chimpanzee do all kids play with Dookie
yeah that's awesome I wonder if my mom
got any Caucus stories about me oh I'm
pretty sure I don't remember
pretty sure cuz I know I have just
always come to my socket are you guys
looking forward to this that's it Bella
was everywhere too because I have so
little kid experience that I don't even
know what it is you never true never
like you should hear his logic he tries
to argue with me he's like yeah argue
with you you argued with her I don't
have any I don't have any like little
babies running around I don't really
know how much expense a kiss
continue what you're in the same you
know argue with me and he'll say [ __ ]
like oh I'm so full Karen where the
first meeting but one of them was ah
they're dead sir um he's just like a
little bit excited as soon as you give
birth to the kid why you just go back to
work with right away and I'm like do you
know there's that whole bonding
experience he's like yup I said yep he's
is Greek I said yes right now nobody is
on your side right now
sound I was on your side for just a
moment you destroy your own yeah so what
you gotta let her finish that report
well yeah I love this argument [ __ ] that
he knows nothing about like it's cool if
you're even like on the earth you're
just questioning or you're curious or
you inquire you mean like that I wasn't
firing when you missed it man and you're
like yeah well want to just do this on
my blog she doesn't want that oh come on
I'm like why are you are you with me no
I guess not very okay fine although you
got to take that time off the bottle not
awesome not nobody believes you do this
dad
oh my god did this was welcome to my
world that's true I forgot you don't
have any mess use Ernie scissors oh
there I do but all my ink the only
experience you have it Isaac not even
you passed all that Isaac was not even
you're like that's closest to any
experience my niece is 31 Jane is gonna
be crazy I never even realize that you
know what you're gonna crack up and when
you public dinner
what a [ __ ] baby tries to talk to you
and they don't have not a speak any
English and all that [ __ ] cracks me the
Father because they just try to copy you
but yeah that is soon a man named yeah
so to speak you [ __ ] Italian [ __ ] I've
seen kids my nephews [ __ ] open up
their diapers sister Hannah Sarah be
like whoa oh my god yeah and then they
like you don't know how to remove it or
no - want something yeah me just like
this and then my cool I went from here
to here oh cool never put any milk
uh I don't know if I remember no that's
why they wouldn't do it yeah I remember
that but it is you want to play like
that me tuners [ __ ] a month left a man
his pop out of the guy in your face sure
like that it like if they have some sort
of logic he'll fill out the logic battle
with them on like doesn't work no I'm
just playing
I'm colliding with them collaborating
daddy can do that too don't feel ashamed
yep I can't you just twist my words
around cuz I'm collaborating and you
think I'm playing logic game we're
tagging with ship together yeah and you
think we're fighting to your house is
gonna smell terrible
that's a lot of Kaka and so his daddy is
from Nebraska
he wrote this really long Facebook post
but I think it's pretty funny something
to read if you guys the whole big yeah
here we go here we go so I was having a
pretty good day
drop the boy off at school work out let
the dogs outside and began chilling like
a boss in my man cave in the basement
like a boss Myra was out teaching her
workout class Alessandra was sleep in
her room and the dogs were outside I had
the house to myself and I was taking
full advantage of watching undefeated
YouTube videos Yeah right
aka jerking off I hear you yeah she
hears before I know he's really trying
to save her I know what's up when you
two
I decided I wanted a piece of the
chocolate cake we made for Jesse's Cub
Scout thing the other day he Japanese
she finished coming o you regardless you
got that so I made my way up to the main
floor as I'm going upstairs
I smell something foul I scan the
basement from the stairs thinking the
dogs dropped a deuce before I let them
outside I see nothing
then my blood runs cold when I realized
the stink is coming from the upper floor
I run up the stairs screaming no no no
no no no till I get all the Sandra's
room
there she is standing at the baby gate
butt-naked holding her diaper covered
head-to-toe in her own crap oh Sh
not talking a little poop here and there
on her I'm talking layered on globs of
human fecal matter covering her arms
legs face and hair it's bad it's worse
than any other time she decided to
explore in her diapers that's when you
gotta turn the sprinklers on until the
kids lay on the grass he had run through
another good one I was tempted to close
the door wait till Mayra got home and
pretend like I was asleep so she would
have to deal with it that's how I'm
gonna do it I should have to do what
that I doubt it but yesterday was
Mexican Mother's days and I didn't want
to be a dick about it
what the hell of executes Mother's Day
I'm a hand is missing what you guys do
under what's it well that's just our
official motto they get a pinata shaped
like a dad and then they beat it balls
there's literally no good place to pick
my daughter up to get her to the bat so
I just knocked the baby gate over so she
can walk out on her own terms
you don't want a crabber and it's just
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] oh no I've smelled a
following I'm pretty bad girl were you
talking about
it's pretty bad but it's still [ __ ]
baby shake if you just [ __ ] wipe it
off with water it's me I'll smells like
it it's already there it's too late
smell it done I put her in a [ __ ]
trash bag and bring her away this is not
the case to death so cut a hole he's as
possible instead of walking out of her
room she smells up at me and extends her
arms for me to pick her up il hell no no
no baby helps us
after a brief stare off she walked out
of her room passes me and head down the
stairs at this point I'm forced to pick
her up because the best wasn't no sir
I used two fingers on both hands to lift
her up
okay and I sell the two of us to the
bathroom I heard baby [ __ ] smells like
[ __ ] - it's like pungent is it worse
than dog [ __ ] my goodness yeah when they
start eating solid foods stairs
what would you say it's the same level
smell as Barth farts the smell is
sharper Anya it's like sharpest it cuts
through everything like yours is densest
but much of it is that if we turn off
the light and we had just like infrared
goggles it would just be this book this
genius
it's a buff art yeah I think because
their inner workings are brand-new and
[ __ ] so just the new [ __ ] smells did it
differently Donald in it yes large spark
is a hammer baby farts is a whip yeah oh
I get type of weaponry gotcha
okay the whole time she's in the tub she
tries to touch me with her [ __ ] covered
hands and I scream like a prepubescent
girl and Dodger after 20 minutes I pick
all the crap out of her hair bottom of
her feet and everywhere in between now
it's time to set foot in her room mind
you I haven't even looked in her room
yet because when I first got to her room
alessandra was standing there like a
[ __ ] covered bridge troll how cute I
thought she had pooped in her diaper and
got it on herself but it was so much
worse I walk in her room
slowly and I'm greeted with a scene
straight out of a German SodaStream
pleasure your watch is boring Todd you
see yeah you all right everything in the
right side of the room is covered and
steaming baby crap the walls the toys
the windows the curtains the play bench
the floor the baby piano my hopes all
covered in crap it looked like a real
category 5 [ __ ] storm blew through her
room Hurricane Katrina if you will ships
raid I have no clue where to start
so I call my Rashi's on her way back
home and I'm on my way to lighting the
health on fire I won't get into any more
graphic details but two rolls of paper
towels five stolen gym towels one bottle
of pine-sol one bottle of bleach one big
bag of crap covered toys and two and a
half hours later her room still smells
like
mr. fire yeah I swear I do everything I
can to show these kids I love them but
they turn on me when I least expect it
Alessandra is my favorite daughter but
my second favorite kid right now
anyway I write these child
interpolations of mine to not only do my
part to spread written contraception and
to strike fear in the hearts of new
parents but also to remind myself that
no matter what I'm going through at
least I'm not cleaning hot baby crap out
of the gears of my daughter's place it
again enjoy the picture hashtag kids are
the worst
oh ho there's pictures yeah holy SH I'm
so cute
you got Giambi here's the daddy you can
see so decrepit and here's it's all my
Goddess everywhere oh all maunder time
oh look here it's on a [ __ ] window
how does that happen you just throw it
kids like hearing it Yeah right in
everywhere and I feel like it's a good
indicator of like what she plays with
yeah after all this [ __ ] out
stood you know what happened like
straight up I'm like very like senses of
smell I just walk in and they were
smelling barked at [ __ ] everywhere that
goes to show you the parenting style
between moms and dads moms are just
there's there's we're like [ __ ] hawks
like put that [ __ ] like the kids'll be
right here put it down no leave it alone
like we're everywhere with dads did they
just go based off of a sound like I cool
they're quiet but moms know back in
Austin moms know when kids are quiet
that's bad that's [ __ ] bad visually
valid toddler if you're not sleeping and
they're quiet they're doing some [ __ ]
[ __ ] smearing almost you guys have
mommy scent though that's true
heightened sense of like [ __ ] that's
going down I want a child even before
they think it or do it they've been
thinking and you go why would you even
do that my job is to bring hamburgers
home that's it that's all my Isaac [ __ ]
three right no no what happened last
week no he was about three years old I
think he was supposed to be sleeping in
his crib so I had a little security
camera there to make sure he was okay I
check security camera and I'm like why
is he out of his crib and I'm like what
is that
over his body like what the [ __ ] what
sound that's on the door so I'm like oh
[ __ ] so I opened the door and I could
see that the door was smearing the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] so I closed the door and I go
around I enter through the other side
I'm like I did what did you do he was
just laughing here's a second mommy look
I'm like oh my god knows [ __ ] everywhere
did you [ __ ] on the floor you took his
diaper off so the diaper was going the
second spot with my body trade that's
when I started fighting I'm like okay I
think you don't actually know you was
younger because here was already fully
potty-trained by 2003 so he was younger
than that maybe - yeah there was like
poop everywhere and I remember smelling
and I was just like oh my god we guy he
pooped on the floor right where the door
opening is that's why smears that [ __ ]
even more but he is not grabbing some of
it you smeared it on the door smeared on
himself I think she's trying to smell if
there is someone in space oh okay I wish
my kid would do that she could I was
straight up [ __ ] [ __ ] on his head
[ __ ] mother well you know you've done
to me so many times - that still at
dreams after he was potty-trained every
night I would make sure you go - he peed
before he goes to bed but still he would
wake up and had accident sometime so
then um there was this like phase that
he had where he would wake up in the
middle that night and just start crying
and crying and crying on like what's
wrong what's wrong and I'm like half
asleep - because like 3:00 or 4:00 in
the morning I'm like what's wrong what's
wrong like it's okay you're okay like
relax
he's am I good until he starts peeing
and he stops crying and I'm like clock
every night for like a consecutive day
I'm like I keep forgetting that he's
crying cause he got to go pee well then
I take him over to the toilet and I he's
standing there he'll see he's on the bar
he'll pee right on the floor right in
front of the toilet like no he writes
back say oh my god it a little potty
training thing and dealing with piss and
[ __ ] when he was a newborn I he pooped
all over mommy she's peed all over me
there's everything I'm so excited for
you guys we should have bought an old
[ __ ] up house on a lot without a
brand-new house all you guys need is a
shopback that
fault everything I'm just trying to
remember every [ __ ] [ __ ] and piss my
kid does on me and when they're old
enough to remember I'm doing right back
wait till they're 18 now it's my turn
[ __ ] I'm gonna take a dump on you yeah
what URIs potty training your baby
already her new born breech she's like a
three-month-old yeah she told me she's
potty training him and so apparently
like you give on the schedule and you
stick with only peeing for now I guess
pooping is another control dose but for
peeing like she she takes them over to
the toilet every couple hours and she
tells and she makes a noise and so for
him to know like oh this is time to put
pee and then she's like yeah he's
already starting to potty training he's
like even she told me that in Indonesia
they do that all the time where they
potty train the babies because they
don't have diapers at least when she was
growing I make sense because you can
potty train puppies and then way dumber
than babies yes I'm like that's genius
I'm gonna do those kids I just leave a
[ __ ] vacuum stuck up his butthole his
coffee set the [ __ ] up that's right shot
back thanks for watching just kidding
news guys don't forget to comment down
below we want to hear what you say only
if it's positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby
[Music]